[Music]
this is a falling seed
and this is a tiny electronic device the
goal of this project has been to add
capability for winged flight to
electronic circuit chips
using seeds as inspiration researchers
have designed tiny electronics that fall
slowly through the air
thousands of which could be distributed
over a huge area
for purposes such as environmental
monitoring maybe tracking the
development of a chemical spill tracking
population movements maybe disease
tracking things that could happen with
tiny devices that are communicating with
one another wirelessly in sort of a
coordinated manner
john rogers and his team started out
studying the aerodynamics of seeds
cottonwood seeds maple seeds that have
developed over the course of billions of
years very sophisticated principles and
aerodynamics and we've been able to
adapt those ideas apply them to man-made
electronic circuit platforms the
spinning of the seeds stabilizes them
and slows their fall allowing them to
spread further from the tree the team
adapted these aerodynamics for their
electronic devices we use laser
projection methods to understand how to
create wings and the attack angles and
the number of wings and the geometries
and the weight distributions to fully
optimize the way that these structures
are flying so how do these tiny devices
compare to the seeds that inspired them
well we think we've beaten biology uh in
a sense uh we've been able to
build structures that fall in a more
stable trajectory
at slower terminal velocities than
equivalent seeds the other thing that
we're able to do is we're able to make
these helicopter flyer structures that
are much smaller
than seeds that you would see in the
natural world but despite their tiny
size these artificial seeds are packed
with electronic components it consists
of an integrated circuit with wireless
communication capabilities a digital
sensor you need a power source maybe
that's a solar cell for example it could
be a very tiny battery all integrated on
a platform that includes the wings to
allow for this control controlled
rotational flight dynamics the flyers
are designed to be made with standard
manufacturing processes and the team
have various ideas for how these
miniature devices could be used one
specific example that we demonstrated in
this paper that combines all of those
elements is designed to monitor
particulates in the air so levels of
pollution as a function of altitude so
these devices are designed to fall at
very slow rates and so they have an
extended interaction period with the
atmosphere and so when dropped at
elevation we can actually monitor you
know changes in ambient lighting uv
exposure chemistry of the environment as
as these structures are falling to the
earth as well as monitoring the air the
flyers could cover a wide area at ground
level a chemical spill in an environment
for example causing contamination in an
environment that will vary over time and
so we envision a distributed collection
of these tiny electronic sensors
providing surveillance and and data
around the nature of that chemical spill
and how it's evolving over time but john
is keen that these devices don't become
a form of pollution themselves we've
been very interested in environmentally
degradable electronic devices so
compostable
conductors
integrated circuit chips that just
naturally dissolve and disappear as they
interact with groundwater for example so
the environmental contamination sort of
the pollution the litter associated with
these devices naturally goes away and
the team have even more ambitious future
plans the other thing that we're
thinking about is how to add active
flight capabilities so not something
that just falls like a seed but
something that could fly away you know
like like a house fly or something like
that that that's much more challenging
obviously but it's something that we
think could be interesting
[Music]